In the last couple of videos
we figured out the electron
configurations for atoms that
only had electrons in the s
and p subshells.
And so we have this
obvious problem.
We also have the d subshell,
which we'll talk about, here,
these bizarre shapes.
And then eventually you even
get into the f subshells,
which are these really kind
of exotic-looking shapes.
And the shapes, they're
interesting to look at and
think about, but they're not
as important for actually
figuring out the
configuration.
So the question arises, what
happens when we start going to
the d and f subshells?
So the general way to think
about it is the energy shell
you're in is equivalent
to the period.
We are in the periodic table.
So, just so it all
fits on one page.
The periods were written out
here to left, but then I
wouldn't be able to finish
the whole table.
So this is period one.
Let me write this in
a darker color.
So period one, two, three,
four, five, six.
I think I barely am fitting
on the page.
Right?
So each row is a period.
And then for the purposes
of figuring out electron
configuration-- we did this in
the last video-- we want to
put helium-- let me just copy
and paste exactly helium-- we
want to put helium
in the s-block.
So we want to put helium
right there.
The reason why, just in case
you're curious of why helium
is put there in the periodic
table, it's because it has
very similar properties to the
other elements in this column
or this group.
Each column is called a group.
And we'll talk about valence
electrons and why that leads
to different properties.
But for electron configuration
purposes, we can
put it in the s-block.
That's not too hard to
remember because
it's just one element.
And it kind of makes sense.
1s1, 1s2, et cetera.
And what you do is you draw
blocks around them.
So I've said multiple times
already that this right here
is the s-block.
This over here on the right
is the p-block.
That's the p-block.
And then this in the middle
right here is the d-block.
And so, if you want to figure
out the electron configuration
of any atom, the way you think
about it, they fill in this
order, but when you go from
calcium, calcium would have
filled out the 4s2, right?
4s1.
4s2.
So if I just do its fourth
energy shell,
it looks like this.
Calcium is 4s2.
And then you start filling
the d-block, right?
What did I say?
I wanted to do-- so
that's calcium.
So now I want to figure out the
electron configuration for
iron, right?
Which is in the d-block.
So it turns out-- and this is
kind of an artifact and I'll
do a little bit more of a
detailed video on this in the
future-- that it actually goes
and backfills the third energy
shell, because all of a sudden
the d orbitals can kind of fit
in the gaps of the third
energy shell.
So what you do is, you go one
energy shell above it.
So whatever period you're in
the d-block, you go that
period minus one to figure out
what energy shell the d-block
is filling.
So iron has one, two, three,
four, five, six elements in
the d-block.
So it's going to have d6.
But it's not going to be 4d6.
It's going to be 3d6.
And I figured that out because
it's in the fourth period and
I subtracted 1 from that.
So this is kind of the highest
energy eight electrons in
iron, right?
4s2.
3d6.
If I said, what are the
electrons that are in the
outermost energy shell?
I would say that there are two
electrons in the outermost
energy shell for iron.
But if I were to say, which
energy shell has the highest
energy electrons, it
would be these.
Let me actually do the whole
electron configuration.
Let me pick up another one.
Let me take, I don't know,
copper, right here.
Let me do copper.
So the highest energy electrons
it has are going to
be one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
Actually, let me not do copper,
because copper does
something very interesting
in real life.
So it actually is one of the few
things that kind of is a
special case.
Let me do a different one.
Let me do the whole
thing for iron.
Sorry to be waffling
around so much.
If you wanted to do the entire
electron configuration for
iron, it would be 1s2.
That's the first energy
shell. soon.
Let me do that in magenta,
right there.
1s2.
And then in, let's say, orange,
then you have 2s2.
And then you have six in the
p section right there.
So 2p6.
Now we're in the third
energy shell.
Let me go switch to
this bluish color.
So then I fill up 3s2.
Remember, this is the s-block.
Then I fill out 3p6.
Fill out those, right there.
Right?
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
And now I'm going to add
these electrons.
Let me pick a nice green.
So then I go to 4s2.
So it's 4s2.
And now this was the interesting
thing, that this
whole d-block is interesting.
Now I fill out another
d-block.
Or my first d-block.
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
But it won't be in the
fourth energy shell.
It'll be in the fourth minus
one energy shell.
It'll be in the third
energy shell.
So this will go to 3d6, just
like we did at the beginning
of the video.
And so it's in the third energy
shell, so I would
actually write it here.
3d6.
So if I wanted to write things
in order of which energy shell
they are, I could have
written it this way.
If I wanted to write
it in order of the
highest energy electrons.
Remember, the shells are kind
of the best way to visualize
how far away we are
from the nucleus.
So in this case, these higher
energy electrons are going to
be further in the nucleus even
though it's a higher energy
state to be in.
If I did it in terms of
energy state, I could
rearrange these two.
But in most of chemistry,
what matters is what's
in the outer shell.
So it's interesting that
although we filled our 4s2
here, and then we kept adding
more and more electrons, those
electrons were just filling
a lower energy shell.
So in this atom, in the case
of iron, when we talk about
the electrons in the outer
energy shell, and those are
valence electrons, and these
are the ones that react.
So that these are called-- let
me do this in a better color--
valence electrons.
This iron has two valence
electrons, because the outer
shell is 4s2.
Even though it had these.
Even after filling 4s2, it had
six more electrons, but those
kind of backfilled the
third energy shell.
So that's one way.
And then, so you might say, well
what happens when we go
to the f shell or the f-block?
And so that's these down here.
So in a lot of periodic tables
you see these lanthanides and
actinides down here.
And they're supposed to fill
in the gap right here.
And that might be a little
hard to visualize.
And I'll show you why
they do that.
You could have just as easily
made a periodic table that
looks like this.
Where you insert them in, where
you push everything to
the right, and you
insert these in.
But obviously this type of
periodic table is a lot
harder to fit in.
You could have done the
same thing with
the d-block, actually.
So in this one, this is the
s-block, this is the f-block,
and this is the d-block.
And then this is the p-block,
right here.
When we were dealing with the
f-block-- so let's say we
wanted to figure out, I don't
even know what element this
is, electron configuration for
this atomic symbol La.
So it's filling out this last
incremental electron.
It fills the f-block.
Maybe I should do it
in lower case.
So it has one in the f orbital
and this is the sixth period,
but with the f-block
you subtract 2.
So you subtract 2 from it.
So it will be 4f1.
And then 6s2.
Right?
The s-block you just
look at the period.
6s2.
And then if you were to
keep going back, you
would then go to 5p6.
So then it would be 5p6.
And then it would fill out these
10 in the d-block, right
there, that are in the fifth
period, but remember you
subtract 1 from the d-block.
So it would be 4d10.
And then it's 5s2.
And you just keep going
back that way.
And it seems complicated at
first, but just remember, when
you're in the s- or the p-block
you just look at the
period you're in, but then when
you start filling the
d-block, it fills in a-- this is
the d-block-- it fills in a
subshell that's one lower.
And when you start filling the
f-block, which are these
really large elements, you start
filling a subshell that
is two lower.
And so maybe in the next video
I'll do a couple of these
electron configurations, because
I think I'm already
out of time.
And I'll actually show you
another way to figure this out
that's often covered in some
chemistry classes.
See you